we'll go into the first question but
once you come to answer you might just
want to introduce
yourselves as well and uh and then we
answer the question so I'll start off
with the questioning
um so in terms of the budget
um what do you predict will be its
impact and both on the current economic
Outlook and on the demand for public
services because that's where most of
our working for all of our work focuses
and we were also quite interested
because it's a big issue at the moment
of what impact you think the budget
announcements will have on the cost of
delivering those services so Mr Johnson
do you want to start on this one
okay uh I'll have a go I'm Paul Johnson
I'm director of the um of the ifs
um
I mean well in a sense there wasn't that
much Direct on public services in the
budget but there's quite a lot in there
that's um that's in direct I mean the
big one which I think will come to later
so I won't talk about now is child care
um but the I mean the broader uh issues
I think a twofold one is the immediate
um where uh We've clearly got
um some serious issues about funding of
um public pay
um requests or demands or um wherever we
end up with that now uh there is because
of what happened in the Autumn and some
additional money in the school's budget
which um broadly speaking might be
enough to in a sense fund the um the the
offer that was put but clearly if you
use that money for the offer then you
don't have that money for the other
requirements after you know more than 10
years of freezing spending in that area
similar issues in in health
um the I mean the the Striking thing
about health spending over this
Parliament is that despite the
remarkable pressures that we're seeing
in health at the moment the spending
increases in real terms that we're
seeing are actually below what was
planned pre-pandemic now
um they're still significant and they're
real but they are but they are below
long-term uh average increases and as I
say quite remarkably in a way they're
below what was planned pre-pandemic
despite what's clearly what is clearly
higher level of demand as not to mention
the the pay
issues so I think those are the sort of
immediate
[Music]
um
issues for public for public services I
mean the longer term ones I think are
really around the uh the numbers that
are penciled in effectively
post-election
um for public service spending which
um bluntly uh I mean I think are
penciled in in order that the the
numbers that are in the spreadsheet meet
the fiscal rules uh because if you make
any kind of reasonable assumption about
what will happen to spending on health
and defense
um and so on you are left with uh Cuts
in in what we frequently call the
unprotected
um department so my presumption I have
to say is that spending will be higher
than is currently planned
um you know either taking advantage of
what may turn out to be a better Public
Finance situation or
um or change rules or raising more
um tax rate I may be wrong about that
but that would be my uh but that would
be my presumption so I think you've got
um you've clearly got pressures in in
the short run but you've also got I
think some probably unrealistic
presumptions about what spending will be
um in the longer run I think the broader
picture of course on public sector pay
is that you can take it so far but as
we're seeing there's there's a limit to
where you can take it we know that
nurses pay on average about 10 down on
where it was in 2010 Teachers Pay 13 15
down particularly for experienced
teachers and the consequences for
Recruitment and Retention and obviously
the
disquiet within the professions is is
already you know very evident and the
government will have to take a decision
at some point uh about the appropriate
level of remuneration in those sectors
I'd agree as you'd expect giving me
expertise um with Paul I mean I think
for me it's almost what we didn't see in
the budget rather than what we did see
which is the biggest question for uh
public services so you all know very
well that the spending envelopes were
obviously set um before we were
expecting quite the inflationary levels
we're seeing so um and we didn't see
extra funding by and large I mean a few
pots here and there but but for
departmental spending which is of course
how you fund public services and I think
um in the you know the sort of I guess
three
huge pressures that public services are
are facing within those envelopes one of
course is increased demand which we may
come on to driven by cost of living
pressures for people and and you've got
kind of direct implications of that more
people claiming benefits or top-ups to
wages uh and then you've got I mean
slightly less direct or slightly more
indirect which is deteriorating health
for example as a result of not being
able to hit your home or you know
restrictions on on expenditure on food
or whatever it might be the stress of
finances so you're seeing demand
increasing on public services as a
result of the the pressures that
households families are feeling you've
of course still got whilst the pandemic
for some may feel quite quite a long
time ago now
um we're nowhere close to dealing with
the long tail of backlogs across Public
Services
um you know the the best guess at the
moment for example in the NHS which is
obviously where we're most evidently
seeing this
um is that actually we've still got
missing referrals from during covid so
by that I mean we haven't hit the peak
potentially of what the backlogs could
look like in elective care so that is
huge demand coming through into the
system and back when the spending review
envelopes were Set uh there wasn't
really funding put in place for
continuing to tackle backlogs uh again
we have had some ports and then of
course you have inflation and that plays
out in in two main ways as Paul was
saying in terms of um pay settlements
and where we're going to get to for the
workforce which has of course also knock
on impacts on the ability if you've got
vacancies to tackle the demand but also
for those departments that have larger
States for example uh all large
workforces and that that kind of
inflationary pressure is particularly
acute so we have spending envelopes
um that I think to be generous will
require more than the efficiency targets
that uh or savings that were already
built in as expectations in in the
spending review which I think was five
percent uh roughly was already expected
so so I think it's going to be a really
tough time for public services but I do
think that um within that and linking I
think to the longer term question
um how we drive productivity in public
services
um has very much come back to the fore
and we have seen a drop in productivity
in certain areas um and so health is a
good example we actually have
um a less activity per per doctoral
nurse per per staff so trying to Grapple
with some of these questions around
productivity what it would actually mean
to drive efficiency in some of the
services and also some tough questions I
think going forward around what's the
role of Public Services versus perhaps
other uh sectors or or or us as
individuals and households so
um so I think that you know extreme
pressure but also I think some
opportunity to think about how we
um
as we would say reform reimagine some of
the public service models so that they
are fit for purpose going forward and
are able to operate within
um you know sound public finances yeah
okay thanks there are some real
interesting questions that I'm sure
we'll come back to I just want to add
two follow-up questions they're quite
tiniest I lost them at the same time in
terms of the extra money that was put
into the health and education budget
last year
uh was that to pay the pre what was the
um the announcement that went with that
to pay the previous salary increase uh
that there's a I hear sometimes that
well you know the offer that's on the
table now and we gave you the money last
year and there's a bit in my memory that
is wondering whether that was to
actually catch up with the previous pay
increase so that's the first question
the second was prior to the budget
there's a lot of talk about an envelope
that the chancellor had to play about
with that there was some extra money
what what happened to that did it vanish
or is that the money the extra money
that was spent on public services in
this budget
your first question I don't I mean the
money the additional money particularly
for Education that was made available
was not in any sense tied to
any increase in in Pay I mean it was
there in order to help the school system
in particular catch up with some of the
cuts over the last decade
um and obviously some of the
considerable strain put on by covid and
um similarly with uh health I mean as
far as I'm aware there's been no
specific additional money made available
to fund an increase in
um uh in paying that sector either so uh
that's uh that that is still um you know
I think to come now I I think that the
proposal for a one-off increase for last
year I think the idea is that that's
relatively easily funded but clearly
going forward if you consolidate bigger
increases then that really creates more
pressure going forward in terms of the
um it was there money to play with
um this is always a slightly strange
kind of you know game that you frankly
get played out in the in the media I
mean what what happened of course was
the public finances deteriorated
dramatically between last March and
November
um and that meant that forward borrowing
numbers went up a lot they then improved
a bit between November and this March so
if you look at the one between November
and March it looks like there's a little
bit more money around over the next few
years you can bear this march with last
marches for less money around in terms
of what you actually saw in terms of the
borrowing numbers going forward because
the obr forecast got a little bit better
compared with November there was lower
borrowing over most of the next four
years but the chancellor used up most of
that Headroom for tax cuts through the
expensing incorporation tax for example
in the child care but actually the um
that that Gap narrowed at the end of the
period which is why some of those
um spent some of that spending in
particular the corporate tax spending is
at least deemed not to be there at the
end of the period and in terms of space
there is no space at all against the
Chancellor's main fiscal rule which is
now debt falling at the end of the
forecast period debt is essentially
stable at the end of the forecast period
it's not really falling
only to say really that there is no
fiscal Headroom based on the fiscal
rules which is the point that Paul is
making and you know I think
um just as a slightly quirky but I think
informative observation that when the
chancellor stood up and said uh with you
know sort of quite some Fanfare that
there was a six point 5 billion buffer
that they built in at the end and then
when you read the OVR document when it
had been published it said oh by the way
since we set those forecasts that 6.5
million has disappeared because of
interest rate changes so I think just
appreciating the volatility and the
difficulty and needing quite large sums
of numbers to actually be a buffer or to
give you you know quotes fiscal Headroom
which of course just means you're
borrowing less it doesn't matter the
money isn't there
um I I think I mean as Paul is very much
saying we had on the head of the OVR in
for an event just after the budget and
he talked about those numbers at the end
as being a kind of fantasy budget so
that probably gives you the context of
how realistic some of those numbers are
very ignorant on these issues so if if
the question is an ignorant one then
please forgive me
you put in in our briefing that we've
got about 5.6 billion uh extra will be
spent on health and education over the
next two years
if you assume that over the next two
years the actual rate of inflation drops
to two percent which is the Bank of
England claimed it would be within that
two-year period if interest rates also
start to come down what sort of effect
does that actually have on the actual
Global sum of that 5.6 billion because
in terms of its spending power will it
get bigger or smaller as a result of
those changes
poor well uh the um I think it's
important to see this in the context of
the increases overall so as I said at
the beginning the um the increase in the
health budget in real inflation-adjusted
terms
um even after extra Money's been put in
is lower than was planned back in um
2019 so I think the so there is extra
money there for Health Service
um relative to where we were and when
you're looking at what Charlotte was
saying earlier there is a reduction in
productivity in the Health Service there
are many there are something like 10
more doctors and nurses and so on and in
terms of measured activity that hasn't
actually grown over that period so
there's a there's a productivity issue
there as well as a resources issue and
of course the to some extent that extra
money that was allocated was to make up
for the the inflation that's already
occurred so um the the numbers in the
the numbers they would have otherwise
got would have been on the Assumption uh
made two or three years ago that
inflation will be around two percent and
the wage Rises will be around two or
three percent and of course things have
changed have looked very much different
to that so I think in in terms of asked
your question is
um I think these services will still
have less than they might have expected
three or four years ago but more than
they would have had had the had the
government stuck to the
um the nominal
spending review plans
okay and of course we haven't
um we don't know what the pay
settlements are going to be within that
context and whether there will be money
to cover uh whatever pay increases look
like and therefore if that has to be
found from within those budgets then
clearly that has implications
right thank you thank you hello Chipley
I've ended up with two questions if I
may
um following on to the question from
Lord Willis about
um the Health Service a question that
I've never fully understood which
perhaps you can explain there are
apparently fifty thousand vacancies in
the NHS it is reported and what I wonder
is if they were filmed filled it's the
money in the budget to pay the salaries
of the people appointed my first
question the second just relates to debt
and the concerns in the last few days
about
um Rising debt and interest rates and
whether an interest rates will fall but
to what extent should the Public
Services be worried about the fact that
their you know the debt Rises and
interest rates are still significant and
they're taking quite a slice out of
public
expenditure at all levels of national
government and local government as well
sorry but that third question is a 50
000 vacancies in the NHS is the money
there to pay the salaries should they be
filled Mr Pickles do you want to start
on this one this time
no my answer is I don't know actually if
they would have allocated that my
working assumption would be there is not
a put there that is being kept available
for you know filling those 50 000 uh
vacancies so so my guess is not and of
course on top of that we are expecting
the workforce plan that we've been
promised to come out uh I would imagine
shortly after the local elections which
presumably will commit to increasing
that Workforce further which I would my
assumption would be that that has to be
new money found I think just it is worth
which it knows a slightly different
comment but I think it's probably worth
just noting that um
the vacancies are very uh they're not
evenly spread across either
geographically or across the roles
within the Health Service so there is a
common view that we have a shortage of
doctors actually if you think about
Hospital doctors we're about 35 more
today than we were in 2010 actually if
you look at the breakdown of the
vacancies The Lion's Share is is is in
Community Care is in mental health is
not actually in hospitals but that's
where our our Obsession tends to be and
there's a bit of a myth that that's
where the shortages are but it comes
back to that productivity point that we
actually have seen a lot more doctors so
um the other thing that that means is
that obviously doctors and particularly
Consultants kind of Specialists are at
the much more costly end of the NHS pay
scales whereas actually the biggest
volume the volume of vacancies is
actually in the um lower paid end of the
workforce but no I don't think there's a
pot that's being kept available for
filling those vacancies
so and it's always so worth sort of
thinking about scale here I mean the NHS
employs so many people uh that I mean if
it is 50 000 that's only a five percent
vacancy rate which isn't bad actually in
most organizations uh but also of course
there's additional costs to the extent
that they're being covered by lucums or
agencies which are very high stuff yeah
um uh but the um but but I think the key
I think the most important point that
Charlie made is that um you know we have
got a lot more Hospital doctors like
twice as many as we had 20 years ago and
no more GPS and no more people working
in the community so we've really skewed
towards secondary care and away from
primary care over that time
um on the on the sort of debt interest
um question uh yes I think I think that
is a worry I mean look we we are in this
why are we in this kind of extraordinary
position in a sense where the tax burden
is rising to its highest level in
history
um and
um you know borrowing is reasonably
significant and yet we seem to have
we're talking about not enough money for
public services well I mean there are a
couple of reasons for that one is very
poor growth
um but another is the very high levels
of spending on debt interest which is
rising back to its sort of highest level
in about 50 or 60
years and that's of course because so
much of the debt is held in
um informants which are variable index
linked guilts which um be really spiked
this year because of inflation but also
the debt that's held by the bank of
England so we've traditionally prided
ourselves all the new Treasury and
management office are prided themselves
on the fact we have long longer dated
depth and most almost any other country
but of course the fact that nearly half
of the debt is now held by the bank of
England means that it's essentially
marked a market interest rates that you
pay on that and that is one of the
things that is is squeezing money
available for public services
um Lord print is followed by Lord Porter
yeah it was a very similar question I
was going to ask the the question about
if the jobs were filled in the Health
Service was the effects on productivity
but the um I'll change its slightly to
um social care because uh 130 000 jobs
no Workforce plan there's no career
structure you're going on the minimum
wage you stay on it for 20 years the um
and yet they we all know that we're in
an aging Society we all know about the
issues as far as care of their children
concerned they um
if we're going to deal with those
problems in Social care
where will the money come from
and then connected with that is you talk
on a number of occasions about
productivity and everybody does
everybody talks about improving
productivity so it's a language of that
we've known in the health service for
maybe the last 20 years how do you
define productivity in terms of helpful
it's a great question uh well you may
want to supportive question I could
certainly talk the social care if I
don't if you want to pick that up first
you go first
um we're just on productivity I mean
it's a fabulous question and it is in
most public services because
um there clearly isn't a simple answer
of saying you know for example what we
end up doing is we end up saying let's
measure inputs and outputs which of
course is activity which isn't
necessarily value and so actually what
we need to be able to measure is
outcomes which becomes incredibly
difficult to do
um and I think in so at a basic level
and the easiest place to be able to
measure productivity is obviously in a
hospital because you can start thinking
about
um I've got this many nurses and doctors
and you know my Workforce this is this
is what I'm putting into the system and
at a really basic level
um how many hip operations or or how
many other elective surgeries or
Diagnostics or whatever it might be what
is the activity that we're actually
doing because hospitals on the whole are
focused on very tangible activities I
think the more interesting question is
what does it look like in Primary Care
um and that becomes very difficult
because how do you measure something not
happening which is actually the outcome
you want to see so we need to shift the
conversation
and actually we need to deliver the
long-term plan which is you know Paul
saying what we've seen is even greater
focus on um and this is exactly where
the money and the power and the
decisions and the people are in
hospitals when the long-term plan
specifically States the ambition is to
shift into community and primary and and
how you measure success there becomes
very difficult not least because again
how do you measure something not happen
but over what time frames as well are
you measuring that so um so I don't have
a good answer I'm afraid uh on that side
but I think in hospitals there is a um
there is a imperfect but important
measure of if we've got more in
hospitals why are we getting less from
them
um in a in a you know a two basic sense
but an important sense I think there
you look at hospitals and you're saying
but we're looking at the hospital system
and the neighborhood problems within it
there's more stuff you know they haven't
got the shortages that people talk about
but isn't one of the reasons that the
hospitals are uh in crisis is because of
primary care not functioning properly
and because as a community care services
they they put the pressure on the on the
hospital so you've got to deal with the
whole Avenue Cole you absolutely do
um there's no doubt about that but there
are also big issues within hospitals
themselves so we published a report a
month or so ago looking at what's going
on in a e so everybody's very familiar
with um the fact that our a e targets
the wait times
um are not quite as bad as they've ever
been because they've just marginally
improved but they're not far off as bad
as they've ever been
um and yet there are
um almost double the number of emergency
doctors in a E's compared to a decade
ago demand has only increased just over
20 so this is not a problem with too
many people turning up also we did a
proxy for our people turning up with
more complex needs going into a e and
that's what's creating delays in the
system
um and that's not really because we use
the proxy of conversion from attendance
to admission which would indicate
there's a complex need
there is nothing wrong with our anes
there's not a shortage of resources I
mean there'll be some implications of
sickness and things like that in as in
staff sickness in certain a E's
problem is patient flow through the
hospital and part of that is patient
flow out of the hospital into social
care which is exactly where your system
challenge comes in but part of it is
actually just that hospitals are not
being well managed and so you have a
challenge with for example
um the right information is not
available to take someone from this Ward
to this Ward or someone hasn't literally
booked the transport to take someone
home or a particular doctor hasn't
signed off a form that is required to
sign off these are this is data points
that finally actually the NHS they
stopped publishing who was responsible
for
bed days where someone shouldn't be in
that bed where they're healthy and well
healthy is probably an exaggeration but
where they're fit to go home but they're
having to stay in a bed and they used to
publish that data and they stopped but
they did a bit of a data dump um uh just
before we published our a e paper and we
think somewhere in the region of 40 of
those days which is a lot of bad days
and freeing up capacity boosting
productivity are actually down to NHS
responsibilities not social care
responsibilities and a big chunk of that
is down to are these places being
managed effectively and so there is
definitely a if you like a purist sense
of productivity challenge in there and
if you look at what's happened to
Staffing levels in the NHS
um actually I mean we've just heard so
doctors have gone hugely up in the last
decade 12 years GPS are basically stable
which is a huge issue and a big problem
um Community nurses are slightly lower
as our maternity managers are
significantly lower and it's a really
unpopular thing to say and I'm not
talking about people sitting in HQ I'm
talking about operational managers we
have a real issue in the NHS about both
the quality and capacity of really good
operational management and ultimately if
you think about the complexity of a
hospital or a trust or now take it to an
ICS level good management is going to be
absolutely fundamental and that is I'm
afraid not it not well enough uh put in
place at the moment
sorry that was a bit of a long-winded
answer but I don't know if you're
interested
oh social care do you want to take
social care
I should start by saying I completely
agree with everything that that
Charlie's just um that Charlie's just
said it's um it's absolutely
um management it's management of staff
and the NHS is in many aspects a very
poor employer you only have to look at
the staff survey results and indeed in
the nhs's own uh plan it basically says
we're a terrible employer and that is
not good for um that is not good for
productivity
um the odd reflection I'd have is this
is sort of second hand and since I'm a
member of the times Health commission
and one of the things that was very
striking from what we've heard from
those involved in health is there's
there's a sense of a culture of being
very very very risk-averse and that
creating a large amount of cost in the
system as well partly to do with getting
people out of the hospital that
um exactly where the responsibility of
the hospital and the social care system
sits depends to some extent on how those
decisions are made and very often
they're made with a very well so I'm
total I mean this is second hand with a
very a sort of
caught in a very kind of cautious manner
um on on
um on social care
um and and the workforce I mean there
clearly is a major issue with uh with
the social care
um Workforce partly associated with a
loss of Starfire as a result of brexit
um and partly just a result of the very
tight labor market that we have at the
moment
um now it's interesting you mentioned
the the minimum wage and you know that's
creating problems for social care and
other sort of Industries in the sense
there's been a real squeeze in the the
gap between someone on sort of
mid-learnings and someone on the minimum
wage and that the minimum wage has gone
up and then there's a sort of concertina
effect above it so that um uh actually
some organizations and industries are
finding it difficult to persuade people
to take more responsibility because the
the net increase in their wages and
terribly uh isn't terribly much but it
also means that there's a little all
there can be little scope for
um for for real progress and that's
that's true in Social care and it's true
um and it's true elsewhere
um but you know the you know it it's
also again it's not just wage it's also
only the the pressure and um uh sort of
pleasure you can get from work if you're
already getting 15-minute appointments
and having to rush between different
um uh between different areas uh in
order between different homes in order
to do that then clearly the workforce is
going to find that much less worthwhile
than um you know periods past when there
was more funding in the capacity to put
more real
um sort of love as it were into in into
the
um into the work in terms of the overall
I mean looking broader at Social care
we've clearly had a period we're all
we're still in a situation where
um much less many fewer people are being
able to access
public social cabin was the case 15
years ago because the not because of the
means testing but because of the needs
testing which has become sharper in
order to ration
um in order to ration what's available
and of course that you know the the
latest change that we had was in the
Autumn statement
um where the reforms which producer
happened this September were pushed yet
again into the into the long grass and
you know it's um you know I don't think
it's a controversial thing to say this
has been a a major long-term failure of
politics in this country for a you know
for a very very long time and
um you know I was uh
it's hard not to be angry about the way
that that's happened
a lot puta
well thanks a lot of a few points and
which is very odd because this is a very
depressing subject and no disrespect to
our two witnesses I'm even more
depressed now than it was before I
started
um
do you think it would help if we had one
five one officers operating in hospitals
like we have one five one officers
operating in local government
I think you might have to explain what
is what that is as well it's it's the
what is the one that stops the
organization spending money willy-nilly
okay
on the on the basis that we seem to have
had complete agreement from every
witness we've had in that more money is
going in and less productivity is being
delivered
and one thing Matthew Parish wrote
please about 20 years ago that said
basically we're on the wrong side of the
1820 inverse that we're not careful with
deal service and we'll just be sticking
a load of results in and aren't we
getting any benefit out of the upper end
and a 151 officer would
be the place where that Stock People
spending money when the business case
didn't work
either of you can go first on this
because I'm not sure your thoughts about
this one
definitely wanted you to okay fine all
right so
um thinking aloud I think this is
exactly this is very very much something
allowed quite so I mean I mean I think
there are several several points in here
so clearly do you need smart
financial management of Public Services
absolutely you do
um and
I think part of the challenge actually
and why we've ended up where we are is
that
um
in some cases uh Finance directors or
those who are within the kind of Finance
functions that departmental or trust or
wherever it is level
um are thinking more around pure cost
constraint than actually what value for
money looks like and I think that is
What's led to some poor decisions
actually where we haven't done the right
Investments that could have led to
um uh quite significant savings down the
line so I think there's something about
what we actually mean where eating
Public Services when we're talking about
value for money because value for money
is
um is very different to just cutting
spending uh so I think there's something
about how we see that now clearly in
local government there is additional
pressure and that they can't really come
back cap in hand in the way that the NHS
can and has and does do uh so you know I
mean I guess Foundation trusts or
Foundation hospitals would have been the
obvious example of the attempt to create
much firmer
um budget it's I think you know the the
positive thing
the at least we're seeing within
um certainly NHS England is that there
is there is a much bigger focus on
productivity efficiency how the money is
spent then I would say we've seen for
quite some time and I think that's
promising I think there is a huge
challenge for
um integrated care uh boards around this
they have been we already know that
they're well over budget
um we already uh know that NHS England
is going to be expecting them to take
significant Cuts I think in the region
of 30 percent uh for some of them
um
I would question whether we have in
place the capability which I think is
going to your point uh within most ics's
to do that sort of
um uh efficiency Drive
um and I think we also have to think
about and I'm not quite sure hopefully
collectively some of this answers your
question but I think we we do also have
to think more seriously coming back to
my where I started at which is if you
you know part of the reason why the NHS
remains a
kind of black hole for funding is
because we've repeatedly failed to deal
with the drivers of demand in the system
or to put it another way we've
repeatedly failed to come up with a
serious strategy for prevention we've
serious model for Primary Care going
forward we still have a model of the NHS
which was invented essentially 75 years
ago when no one had heard of dementia
diabetes you didn't have
multi-morbidities you know you were
basically creating what was Visionary at
the time but to fix episodic care uh
needs you know so actually if you really
wanted to sort out fiscal sustainability
or financial sustainability NHS you
would look at the model and you'd have
real conversations about how to reduce
demand and we're not seriously doing
that at the moment sorry that was again
a bit of a roundabout oh no it's very
way perfect answer
foreign
I don't have an enormous amount to
um to add to that I think there's um uh
I mean there are a number of issues here
I mean I'll come back to the point about
you know you you're not going to run an
efficient service if you don't manage
your staff well and if they're you know
if if you have a staff survey set of
Staff server results that you get in the
NHS that is going to be a it's not
likely to be an efficient productive
organization I think there's a there are
questions also about
um the role of uh care and treatment and
Diagnostics and so on in hospitals as
opposed to outside I mean hospitals are
where everything happens but in in truth
they're probably places where you need
to do the things you have to do in
hospitals and actually do other things
elsewhere
um and we we don't have a system like
that
um and we also need more clarity I think
about how the system sees itself as
always the provider and deliverer or can
it also be the partner and commission of
services and ensuring that that happens
in a way that is as efficient as
possible and makes use of tech
technological change and and Innovation
and so on that happens in in other parts
of the in the private sector and
um and elsewhere and we need to be clear
I I think that the NHS is there to
ensure that people get treatment free at
the point of use not necessarily always
to be the organization that delivers it
but then you clearly you need to manage
that in a very in in in a very careful
way but I think that you know Charlie's
last point about managing demand is so
important here I mean in a world in
which you know you you you're sort of
managing demand sort of by default by
waiting list
um uh by discouraging people and turning
up
um and so on rather than by being
explicit about how you're going to do it
uh you know the costs of that in the
long run are potentially very high
indeed and come back again to something
um Charlie said they'd answer it earlier
question it is really really worrying I
think the extent which we still have
millions of people who didn't turn up
for treatment during covet who still
haven't turned up and
um you know in one sense it's it's a
miracle the waiting list is as short as
it is because if um if any fraction of
them not we have not had one more person
joining the waiting list than we would
have expected pre-pandemic which is
astonishing the reason waiting this has
got up is because the treatment has
slowed down at the other end
um and you know there is a you know who
knows what's going to happen as a result
of that but that could uh I mean that
you know if that takes up and this is
why Sajid Javid when he was Health
secretary a couple of years ago whenever
it was said that he thought there's a
risk of a 12 or 13 million waiting list
and it was that was on the basis of only
a fraction of those who missed treatment
during the pandemic turning off and if I
imagine very briefly because
um do you think it's a really important
point
um we are essentially rationing care
that's what we're doing with wait lists
and with inability to get a GP
appointment we are we are literally
rationing care so that's not really a
universal service at that point if
people can't access the care they need
and the result is early deaths
disabilities pain you know people
dropping out of the workforce because
they can no longer work because of of
these Health needs but just coming back
to the observation that um we're being
rather depressing here I I would like to
say that there are quite a lot of
examples internationally of different
ways of approaching Health which are
delivering much better outcomes at lower
cost and I think part of the challenge
if I may is to say that I think we've
had too much of a sort of exceptionalism
view of the NHS and actually we've been
reluctant to look at other countries and
I'm not talking about you know creating
a private insurance system you know if
you look at some of the stuff they're
doing in Singapore around digital and
public if you look at Israel and home
hospitalization in the use of Technology
you look at you know Finland Denmark
Spain they've all got examples of things
we could be doing better to deliver the
model that we all know we need which is
greater Community Care greater
self-management greater use of
technology which can lead to some of
that demand reduction
but we're just not doing it so I think
there is hope there if we're willing to
learn from places that are doing things
differently and accept that that doesn't
mean that we're criticizing NHS but the
only way to save the model of the NHS is
to start changing how we approach it
yeah I'm conscious that Lord Carter
wants to come in but I'm also conscious
that I'm not goes on to question two yet
and um
they are a bit more specific so what I'm
going to do Lord Carter that's all right
Bernard Stephen Scott ask question two
and hopefully you can tell your question
is it's a generic because we'll get to
it something yeah yeah
um thank you for your briefing sheets
which are really helpful
I have two things I'd like to ask
firstly
um notwithstanding the points you're
raising the in the briefing sheet about
perhaps 70 000 pounds per job created
um as a result of trying to get people
back to work as a result of health
issues and economic inactivity but how
effective will the government's measures
on Child Care be towards the stated aim
of increasing employment and growing the
workforce and my second point is
um is there a way
I'm not asking you how but do you
believe there's a way to create a new
child care model
and have we really looked at who's
making it work around the world
and I cite the examples of Australia and
Canada
I start
um you did analysis right I'll leave the
difficult bits there
um so
um in terms of how much difference the
the announcement will make to numbers of
people coming into the workforce
um it's clear that the large majority of
the money spent will go to people who
would in any case have been at work so
um if if the purpose of this is to bring
people into the workforce then
inevitably
the large majority of the money we think
I think I think something like five six
of it will be dead weight in the sense
that it will simply uh which will be
great news for people who are spending a
lot on child care I mean because I think
partly part of the purpose of this of
course is to relieve the cost of living
pressures on people who are already
choosing uh to both be um in work so
it's perhaps unfair to call it dead
weight but if if your only purpose were
to bring people into work uh then uh
something like five six of it will
probably be deadweight
um the um the obr's estimates of the the
numbers and I forget the exact numbers
it's something like 70 or 80 000 who
might be brought into work by this are
based broadly speaking on some analysis
that we've uh we and colleagues did at
the ifs it's you know it's very
uncertain but it's it's probably the
right order of magnitude but that's not
you know that that is not a big number
in the context of a world overall the 30
million I mean this is a tiny overall a
tiny number of people and even in the
context of the numbers we've lost since
the pandemic it's a small number and and
you know it is dwarfed by just changes
in assumptions about numbers of
immigrants say so that's just to give
some sense of scale in terms of the the
policy
um it's uh it remains a um
it's part of a longer Term Policy by
which child care has become more focused
on
um a Public Service which is for people
where both parents are in work in order
to encourage work rather than where it
was more focused 20 years ago on helping
those on the lowest incomes and
providing high quality child education
so we've moved very much in that very
much in that direction over the last
over the last 20 years but again it is I
mean this is a relatively limited offer
in some sense and this is not going to
give you 40 hours a week 52 weeks a year
or anything like it I think it works out
at an average of 20 something 22 hours a
week over a year
which will obviously help a lot but for
those mothers for example who use 22
hours a week we know that working 22
hours a week is not very helpful for
long-term to put it mildly for long term
development in the labor market if
that's what if that's what the purpose
if that's what the purpose
um but that said you know this appears
to me to ask to be you know yet another
step in the creation of what you know
over the last 20 years has been a whole
new leg of the welfare state where we
you know 25 years ago the state really
didn't do anything in terms of providing
child care it's now providing child care
for or we'll be providing free child
care for a significant amount of time
for a large number of children between
nine months and and school age and that
is a you know that is a substantive
um that is a very substantive change
um over that over that period but as I
say with a a stepping back from
um doing this in order to support the
development of the most disadvantaged
children
yeah I think that Paul's point about
um what is the what's the objective of
child care and I emphasize the word care
has been quite important because
um and this is absolutely kind of not a
view on on the quality of any individual
child minor out there but there is a
difference between a sort of babysitting
function
um to allow parents to go out to work
and high quality early years
interventions and I think we haven't had
that conversation at all
um
and there's also a question here I think
about is the overarching it should the
overarching aim of government to be to
increase by 60 000 the participation
rate of parents or might we want to
think about the fact there's quite a lot
of evidence showing that in those early
years having a parent at home can have
quite a big impact on the development of
that child so again thinking short-term
long-term uh value from taxpayers pounds
you know is this going to actually be
the best value
um and also there's a you know the there
is definitely I think
um a question mark about what a people
families want as well from
um uh for their children and and the
development of their children
setting that aside which I think are
sort of slightly more kind of perhaps
not philosophical questions but um a
bigger uh page questions will it achieve
it I mean Paul is the expert on kind of
how solid the behavioral uh assumptions
are and I think you know we would say
probably good but you wouldn't want to
stake your lunch on it
um so we'll see uh if if they do turn
out to be 60 000 in work
um but there are clearly massive
challenges here of of achieving that so
so where is the workforce coming from
and we've talked about Workforce in
Social care we've talked about Workforce
in NHS and we're broadly in the public
sector but you know if you talk to
people in the industry they will tell
you they're struggling to recruit so
there are some incentives in the budget
around some grants some upfront
incentives which is good
um and hopefully that will make a
difference but this is not a well-paid
industry either so how are we going to
you know how if you're competing and you
know you're kind of I mean actually
potentially earning if you're
self-employed less hourly than the
minimum wage and you can go to older or
little or another supermarket and earn
you know significantly more why wouldn't
you do that so so I think this again
falls into that category of how are we
thinking about
um the workforce uh and whether we have
a Workforce that can actually deliver
the ambition that we're setting out here
in term in policy terms and then of
course there's the questions about
whether the increase in the hourly rate
of payment actually is going to be
sufficient to cover the costs
um which is another thing and again I
mean you know you might say well the
sector would say they want they need
more money wouldn't they but there
probably is something in whether this is
sufficient to actually to meet the
demand that you're potentially creating
um so again some question marks there
about whether it's you know the test of
all policy surely is whether it's
deliverable and I'm not sure we've
answered all those questions as to
whether this one is deliverable
um so so I think there are some quite
big big uh big issues that we'd need to
think about I think the one thing I
would want to say which I think is
fantastic stick that was in the budget
is pulling forward the child care
coverage for UC claimant so for benefit
claim it's now getting that money up
front rather than arrears is actually
really quite a game changer I think and
is it is it I think will make a big
difference I think it's really positive
also the fact that the amount you can
claim in Universal Credit has been
operated by CPI to actually from when it
was being frozen so the amount you can
now get in UC is is I mean hundreds of
pounds more uh so I think that actually
the bit that is targeted at low-income
families within the means tested system
is actually really positive and
hopefully we will see a shift of people
into work from that
um but obviously that's a much smaller
element than the much larger amount of
money that is going to those who are
already in work I guess I would probably
be I mean I don't have children but I'd
be maybe slightly more sympathetic to
saying that there probably are some
middle-income families for whom you know
you might have a woman working to
basically pay child care costs so I
think there is some value in recognizing
the system is quite fundamentally broken
in terms of course which I knew you
would say as well
exactly and recognizing that it's dead
waiting it comes back to what's your
purpose right what are you trying to
achieve with this so um so I think there
are some some questions there as well uh
and on the internationally and is it you
know the childcare model is much like
the social care model right it's broken
it doesn't work there's not you know
we're paying the workforce peanuts to do
really important caring jobs but we
can't seem to work out a system that
actually would enable you to have higher
wages in these really vital roles yet
the private Market isn't really stepping
up to to kind of come up with an
alternative solution so if there are
examples and I don't know I've not
worked on on kind of child care models
around the world but if there are
examples where countries are doing it
better then my goodness of course we
should be going and looking at them and
seeing if we can improve the system
because it's not really working it's
really expensive we spend a lot actually
on Child Care people forget that in this
country for far worse outcomes much like
is the case in a lot of our well
you've got people who are paying more
for their child care they're now off
their mortgage yeah and that's I decided
not to go you know exactly yeah yeah I
think it's I'm pregnant then screwed I
think is the campaign great pressure
group who reckon about 17 of people of
of women in particular fall out of the
labor market because of the cost but it
seems the motivation for this child care
push much as it's welcome to Universal
Credit recipients is to get people into
the workforce well it might be I mean I
think it's interesting to sort of just
look past the rhetoric because you know
I mean actually it's also as I said most
of the money will go to making people
with children better off and I I think
you know the reality is that that's
that's a significant probably the bigger
part of the the purpose of this I think
it's worth
um it's worth making one extra point
which is that um well two exercises as
John's saying we do spend I mean
certainly after this we will be spending
a lot of public money on Child Care
um in a way which just doesn't seem very
effective
um so you know again we need to be
thinking about the model
um for payment and delivery the other
thing to do just just just just bear in
mind is that um whilst yes there are
um you know and 20 years ago I was in
this position there are lots of families
paying a lot of money for child care the
median spending on child care for um
families with children under five is
zero so most families are not that's
partly because it's so expensive they're
deciding not to do it but actually
um you know it is a it is a relatively
small minority of families who are
spending a very large amount on child
care
costs may be pushing others away from
spending money on child care and even
given the um uh availability at the
moment quite a lot of families aren't
using the maximum available now some of
that may be because there's other costs
um if also we do we do need to keep
those facts in mind the average family
is not spending a lot on Child Care
um but it's uh it's uh but but it may be
that's because it's so expensive that
they feel pushed out but it's it's not
the case that the average family is
spending that but there are you know 20
or whatever who are spending a very
large amount okay chippy let's introduce
the next topic as well and then we can
yeah on the same day as the uh the
budget
um that was published the health and
disability white paper you both made
comments and around that time uh um on
the issues around work
capability assessments and I just
wondered if you could say a bit um to us
about what you think the assessments uh
the changes to capability assessments
are going to have for the people who
receive health related benefits and for
that participation in the labor market
so what will the impact be on the labor
market
um as well as on them personally
but some
I you know I don't know the answer I
mean it I think this is a very
um yes ministerish term courageous
policy
um uh you know in the positive sense as
as well as in the sense that it's quite
risky so in the positive sense I mean
what's Happening Here is the idea is
that um uh essentially
um move to a single disability payment
which is
um not related to work capability
um and which looks a bit like the way
that a personal Independence payment
Works um at the moment
um now that's positive because at the
moment a lot of you you get a
significant increase in your Universal
Credit
um payment if you get this work in
capacity element to that so there is an
incentive on you to show that you can't
work
um and that may we don't have I think
anything like positive you know strong
evidence on this that may be
um taking some people further from the
labor market than we would we would
um the reason I say that it's risky is I
think twofold I think one is if you look
at the numbers of people on incapacity
and disability benefits over time it is
that personally Independence payment
group that has just gone ever upwards so
we're moving all of it into that group
as it were that's been moving ever
upwards so there's a risk that some of
the people
um on you know it's some more people
will move into that category the other
risk is that there will be some people
currently receiving the um uh work
incapacity element of Universal Credit
um who apply for personal Independence
payment and I can't remember Charlie
probably remembers the numbers there are
significant numbers of those who are not
currently on pip who who fail that
assessment and then you will be looking
at a world in which a significant number
of people who
um uh were receiving
um higher levels of Universal Credit
because they have some some of sickness
or disability are then taken off that so
you're either going to be spending you
either risk spending your budget more or
you risk taking people off benefits who
who have hit the two being entitled so
but but the thinking behind it like is
entirely you know what I entirely
understandable because of this world in
which we're basically asking people to
declare themselves in unable to work in
order to get more money
um
so I I'll declare an interest in that we
wrote a paper uh back in I think 2016
recommending almost exactly this policy
um uh called working welfare and I
recommend everybody uh uh reads it
um so I mean Paul is
uh articulated the the big issue with
the work capability assessment which is
that it is you know the the objective is
to fail this assessment the objective is
to prove you cannot work and therefore
if you're actually someone who and and
by the way that's a totally rational
Behavior to do that
but then if you're someone who actually
would quite like to work and you think
well maybe I'd like to try doing a job
but then you're terrified of trying it
because what if it doesn't work out and
then you've just true proven you did
have some capacity and now you can't get
back on the benefit so the whole thing
is building in what I would call very
perverse incentives around behaviors
here and you know it is interesting to
think slightly and I won't give a full
history lesson I could I could be very
geeky on this topic but
um the WCA was was and employment
support allowance the original benefit
that it was applied to was um invented
by new labor and it was John Hutton at
the time who said uh you are more likely
to die or retire on incapacity benefit
which obviously it's predecessor benefit
than ever moving to work once you're on
IB and so the point of creating
employment support allowance with this
assessment was to try and prevent that
it was and the Assumption was that a
million people would come off in
capacity benefit as a result of
introducing this and that did not happen
because the way it's designed is not
there to incentivize people to to move
into work it's there to incentivize
people to show they cannot work at all
so so the principle of removing I think
is incredibly positive and I think the
the question about what could that do
for labor market participation of course
actually right we really don't know
because this is really quite pioneering
globally this is one of the actual few
cases where we are trying to do
something ahead of the curve because you
know so many countries around the world
have had seen the same increase in in uh
disability uh benefit claims or
caseloads
um so I don't think we do know but this
certainly removes one of the significant
barriers to to being able to try work uh
that is in place at the moment
I think that this
is worth thinking about here is that it
will only work if there is the right
Support Services though in place to
actually enable those people who are on
who have a health uh a a health
condition or a disability to move closer
to into and then sustain work and I
don't think we're in a position yet
where we have the right Support Services
in terms of the risks and again that
Paul identified I think there are
um there are probably two main
unanswered questions in that white paper
one is how you apply conditionality
because conditionality at the moment is
dependent on uh the category you're put
in so if you're in that category that
says
yes you failed the work capability
assessment you get this additional
amount of money not only is it you get a
decision amount of money but it's also
bye-bye we're just not gonna we're not
going to require anything of you anymore
we're not going to provide anything for
you anymore essentially
what happens now if you don't have that
indicator as to whether you're going to
start requiring people to engage with a
work coach or a support program or some
type of service and that hasn't been
decided and obviously you get into quite
tricky territory of applying
conditionality to people who have a
health condition the other thing is this
question about notional losers and I
think it's important to say notional
losers here because this the working
assumption is that there will be
transitional protection as there was
when Universal Credit was introduced so
so in theory no one who's currently in
receipt of these benefits is likely to
lose out any money the question is new
people coming through and of course
they've given themselves well done to
DWP a very long period of time to
actually get this right they've
obviously learned from Universal Credit
uh and and built in a good time frame
um and the majority of people who are
unlikely to be eligible for pip uh uh
which again is important that pip is
about extra costs so if you don't have
extra costs relating to your disability
or your health condition you won't get
to pip and the big increase in the
caseload of
UC or Esa has been in mental health
and uh the Lion's Share of that is about
half of the queso now is mental health
on these benefits and the Lion's Share
of that is a category called behavioral
and mental and behavioral disorders of
which most of those means depression and
anxiety
most people don't have extra costs
because they have depression or anxiety
it's also conditions that with the right
support you very much should be able to
live with even overcome so that's where
you get into the question of okay so
those people who aren't going to get the
additional money because they wouldn't
be eligible for pip in future because
they don't have extra costs
um which is the purpose of that benefit
how are we going to support those people
to to manage depression anxiety the
mental health disorder they have in
order to be able to be in work and and
then sustain work and that I think is a
really interesting question because if
we can if we can nail that I think we
can have a huge impact on disability
employment
very interesting
well of course did you want to come in
which I sort of well I was really
it's really a couple of points just on
the quantity of Labor that's available
in the market is there a is there a
model for the whole economy I mean you
make the point that I think 70 000 jobs
coming in if we get the child care right
and then 245 000 net migration a year I
mean basically are we going to run out
of Labor
well I mean because particularly in
public services where it impacts low
wages and that end of it I mean in the
end I mean the the economy will come to
a some sort of equilibrium and don't
forget that you know in other parts of
the woods you know I get asked are we
going to run out of jobs because of AI
and and so on and I I mean I I guess I
think in the end we will get to um an
equilibrium where we're you know we're
neither running out of jobs nor running
out of
um labor because we will we will have to
increase the wages in those areas or
companies will have to increase the
wages in those areas where they're
really necessary
um uh or
um the sectors will dwindle
um now you know that may mean
um the the structure of the economy
changes so you know if we if we can't
bring in migrant labor to pick
strawberries or what have you then we
won't have any strawberry farmers and um
it will come into equilibrium in that
way rather than in equilibrium by
bringing more people in to pick the
strawberries that I mean nothing against
strawberry Growers but um
is another way of sort of asking that
sort of question
or or thinking about the
um counterfactual is what would have
happened had we not had the several
million additional immigrants over the
period from the year 2000 will we just
have a very different economy to the
economy we've got
at the moment I don't know in what way
it would be different but we wouldn't
sort of we wouldn't be sitting here
thinking my God we're five million
workers short we would just have a
different
um sort of set of
um different set of services and goods
being produced and a different structure
of our economy now it's not a
particularly helpful answer but I think
the question is
sorry would it be less prosperous then
um I mean if we want growth
well if we I
again you know most of the evidence
suggests that um immigration immigration
clearly increases overall size of the
economy and it increases the tax base
particularly in a world in which you've
got an aging populations that increases
the tax base for paying for the older
population and to a remarkable degree
and we've had in the last 50 years we've
had no increase in the fraction of
people over pension age relative to
under pension age and part of that's to
do with increase in pension age but part
of that's to do with last numbers uh
people coming into the country what it
does for average productivity per worker
much less clear it may be uh that had we
not had this additional labor often and
some of them working in relatively low
paid jobs we would have been forced into
higher levels of capital investment and
higher levels of um productivity but but
that is speculation and and the truth is
that most of the sort of economic
modeling of this kind of thing is done
off the basis of marginal change changes
or over short run and it's really really
hard to sort of determine what the long
run sort of impact on the economic
equilibrium is of of that kind of thing
in the short run in response to your
question yes I mean you know we clearly
are running out of Labor and things in
areas like social care
um at the moment because we had a sudden
change in numbers of people from other
countries in particular coming in and a
sudden change in the demand for labor
from other parts of the economy and
that's been very hard for a service
which is constrained by public spending
to just do in other parts of the economy
in the private sector you'll get
adjustments through changing the way
that things are done or by increasing
wages or or reducing services in a way
which doesn't look you know quite quite
the same as where you've got a
um you know you you've got a effectively
a public service where you're trying to
deliver within a fixed budget that's
that's different from what you see in
the private sector so continued pressure
really for the foreseen the future
if I make can I I think the Assumption
though that it
to drive that greater Prosperity we must
have more people I mean clearly that you
know when you have questions no no
exactly but I think they're absolutely
um but I think there there has
historically been an assumption around
that but part of the challenge which
Paul is saying is that if I mean if you
kept compare us internationally both in
terms of capital investment and
investment in skills we don't we don't
fare very well so actually we haven't
really been investing either in human
capital kind of physical or technology
in the same way as in the way we should
have been doing
um and you know I mean there's all sorts
of brilliant tiny examples like if you
go to a supermarket uh on the continent
most of the pricing on the shelves will
be electronic whereas if you go to a
supermarket here you have to have
someone going around and replacing
pieces of paper so if you you know it
part of the question is how do we how do
we get more from the people we do have
and part of the answer has to be and you
know it's the age-old I mean you know
sort of stating the blindly always here
but part of it is actually about skills
and investment and that's both by
government but also by businesses that
have been under investing in skills but
also in technology and you know we've
touched on that whether it's social care
or whether it's you know in health or
whether it you know any of these things
we could be doing better
even with the workforce we have which is
not to say that we don't still need to
be thinking about
um what that Workforce looks like going
forward well can I just one more thing
yeah just simply just a management I
want to go back to your NHS example
you've been systematically pointing out
that the NHS has got significant
resources but you identify a management
issue and that seems to be true of
everything that the resources we've got
is do we have as a nation and
particularly NHS a real management issue
the ability to use the resource as well
so we definitely do in the NHS um and
we've been looking at that um we don't
look at the economy more broadly I mean
that's probably something Paul that you
could answer but certainly in public
services
um there are there are issues around as
Paul was saying how we deploy our people
How We Do flows through any kind of
process the the sort of the ability to
identify opportunities for savings or to
be more efficient and that all comes
back to how you're managing a service so
certainly in public services in general
yes I definitely would say we do yeah
and more broadly there is really very
good evidence that
um uh the quality of management in in a
country and in a in an organization
really is important for the productivity
and performance of that organization
some former colleagues of mine John Van
reenen and Nick Bloom have done these
studies across the world and shown very
strong causal relationships between
management quality and success and
productivity of organizations in both
the public and the private sector so it
really is something that it's important
both economically but also for the
provision of Public Services to focus on
okay Lord Porter
thanks uh just on that productivity line
um I think most people know that either
if you don't invest in skills or
mechanization then you either import
workers or you export jobs on all the
other restaurant with that workflow
but
because I don't really understand the
kind of the maps sitting behind it if
somebody was able to do a Saturday
morning
and obviously you'd want to incentivize
that by making it tax-free because the
chancellor and they're ready to end all
that money in the first place so not
taking it off of them on the Saturday so
if they did an extra four hours a week
that kind of gave them the same value as
what inflation has taken off of their
wages does that mean count as increased
productivity or is that just
the same as less work for more workers
it's uh it depends how you're measuring
productivity so if you're measuring it
as productivity per worker then yes it
would increase productivity because
you've got the same number of workers
but doing more hours if you do it as
productivity per hour oh yes then it
doesn't make any difference to
productivity and actually you probably
should think about it in terms of
productivity per hour because that's the
actual amount of effort being put in and
again when you're looking at
International comparisons it really
depends really matters what you're
looking at here so um you know we we
look
um you know particularly yeah we we we
um we've got a lot of hours being worked
in the UK
um relative to some other uh to some
other countries
um and also you know relative to
increasingly relative to other countries
quite High numbers of people in work as
well if you look at the productivity per
sort of Person of working age
um actually we don't look so bad as we
do in terms of productivity per hour
worked because
um we we compared with some countries I
mean France for example we have more the
average number of hours worked by people
between the ages of 18 and 65 is higher
but they produce less per hour
so mechanization is going to be the only
way then
if if that's if that's what we're
aspiring to reach is
the level of productivity of a place
like France then the only way we can do
it is by increasing the number of people
who invest in machines that end up
decreasing the number of people working
well it's a combination of um you know
you need you need education and skills
you need investment in in in all sorts
of things not just mechanization but uh
you know in in processes
um
I'm a bricklayer by trade and telling me
to have a degree won't make me lay more
bricks the the degree is the thing that
stopped me having to lay bricks
they don't need more education they need
more hours to work more faster but you
might have people who are more skilled
at bricklaying than others and so I mean
that may not be a good example but but
you it wouldn't necessarily be you need
a robot to come and start laying the
bricks to use the sort of example to the
extreme it may just be that there are
some new methods again I'm probably
clutching at straws with the brick
example in particular but um but they
necessarily mean getting a degree or
even thinking of in an academic sense
it's just you know I have have we got
people who are skilled for the roles we
want them to do and and how are we then
deploying those skills in the most
effective and efficient way and I think
there's still there's still question
marks over that before you even get to
the and can we automate things and can
we use technology to speed up processes
and and all that sort of stuff so so I
think it is probably a a combination of
those two things I'm really conscious
I've already gone two minutes over the
time so um I'm sorry I'm going to close
it though that's Lord Wilson Lord
Prentice so I'm depriving of another
question but I do think it's been a very
wide-ranging discussion
that you might have raised have been
answered in the discussion so far we're
very grateful to you both I think I can
certainly speak myself I've certainly
increased my understanding of what is
quite a complex issue and uh you've
delivered it in a way which even I find
easy to understand than it's not my
strongest suit so thank you very much
for your time and the contribution
you've made to the committee I will
close this part of our meeting thank you
thank you very much